ok let's get into audience questions for
the week very good questions this week
the first one comes from a Reddit user I
never say this right nostalgic saying
cyan cyan I know it's some videogame
thing and I never know how to say it
anyway the question is how come the left
doesn't have grifters like the right I
love this question because there's
actually a lot to it it might sound like
an ad hominem it's a way to criticize
right-wingers listen this is a real
thing
the right has these grifters who were
able to they suffer from audience
capture where they start modifying what
it is that they put out there in order
to appeal to an audience even if these
are not really their political beliefs
but that would only work within or in
front of a certain audience because of
the cults of personality that the right
rewards this is one of the big
differences between independent
left-wing media and independent
right-wing media I've seen it myself I
can have people who like 95% of what I
say and as soon as they don't like some
5% I say oh you know what I don't think
Tulsi gabbard's a great president or hey
you know what I think the squad lacks a
lot of the political skills to make
progress on some of these issues that
are important to them or hey you know
what
I don't think Israel is a uniquely blood
lusting bad actor while I do disagree
with their administration and their
foreign policy there is no cult of
personality around me because
immediately people who have been with me
for years will completely abandon me now
we can talk about whether that's good or
bad for the movement but with the right
you see cults of personality develop
such that these individuals can do no
wrong they build a following for their
personality not what they stand for not
what they believe and not what they say
but for the sort of role that they are
given by the right the left both doesn't
allow these grifters to build around
cult of personality and is quite frankly
not interested in them in the same way
we've talked before about how you will
see very different reactions from left
and right when
there is a political scandal when I'm
not talking about Hillary's emails right
I'm talking about actual scandals the
right will try to cover them up and make
excuses for the people and try to make
the scandal go away to keep the person
in power or even give them more power as
we saw with Brett Kavanaugh on the left
when we find out Anthony Weiner has been
caught sexting with a fifteen-year-old
or whatever people just want him out we
want to move on we have ideas and
principles and policies that we want to
see made a reality and as soon as we see
that somebody is behaving in a way that
doesn't make sense we want them out
there was this audio recording that was
recently covered up by Republicans in
Texas where a Republican came up with a
Republican hit list of Republicans to
primary and Republicans said this the
recording of this conversation is so
damaging we've got to cover it up if I
found out that someone on the Left took
place in such a meeting and I found it
that and I found it distasteful or
disadvantageous I would want the audio
tape out I would want to figure out who
did the wrong thing and I would want
them out so again the the the left
simply doesn't allow the grifting to
become profitable the way the right does
it doesn't create an environment in
which one would succeed by doing that
now I know I'm not stupid
I know half the YouTube comments will be
but David you are a grifter that's not
an actual argument I hope you understand
it is the audience's that decide whether
grifting will work on the left or on the
right
it is the audience's that decide can
someone build a career around a cult of
personality merely because some
think-tank is pumping money into them
and what you see is that the answers are
yes on the right and mostly no on the
left